all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day yes I'm aware I have a
girl character now it's you know just
because I want to scam people not true
at all I had to do a quest but what we
are here for today is a low-level
moneymaking guide I know it's something
that I don't do a lot on my channel and
I might kind of open myself up to um
just because I've kind of made some of
the best highlevel money-making guides
that there are like other than a zoraa
guide which is way too in-depth and
people already know how to do and
there's already better guides than what
I'd probably be able to make so I've
kind of I've kind of exhausted a lot of
my like best GP per hour ones up there
so I figure I'll focus on some of the
people on my that watch my channel that
can't do those money-making methods so
today we are not at the GE we have a
different background cuz I thought it
looked pretty sick and I didn't want to
teleport back to the GE so this is going
to be a magic uh money-making method you
barely need any money at all I'd say you
probably need about 300K 350k just to
keep yourself going for about an hour's
time which isn't bad at all so for from
there you'll be able to make about 360k
an hour and gain about 32,000 magic XP
so it's not too bad at all um if you're
a lower level as far as alking goes
you'd be able to get probably around 60k
XP per hour and it's not AFK you have to
click but I mean with this this is an
AFK money-making method you're going to
be able to get half a little over half
the XP per hour which isn't the best but
at the same time you're making 360k GP
per hour in an AFK method so if that
sounds good to you we're going to going
to get on into it so going to move on
over to the inventory now basically what
you're going to need is in my in my
scenario what you're going to need is
Earth runes one Earth Rune one law Rune
and one air rune for however many times
you want to do this and then also one
soft clay for each for however many
times you want to do this personally I
don't know why I bought double um but it
is what it is from there you're going to
need some coins and not a lot if you
bring like 100k you'll be good for a
long time I'd imagine you'd be good for
about like about a thousand trips so
you'll be all right um from there you
don't need teleports of houses those are
what I'll be making if you haven't
already caught on so this is going to be
using the lecture I think is what it is
called in a play around house to go
ahead and make teleport tabs it's
something that some people do in the
game as you guys can see right here it
is somewhat popular because of its AFK
and Magic XP but yeah um lecture there
you go but what we're going to do is
just kind of go through how you're going
to want to do this so obviously if you
don't have this in your own house which
I do not you can just go ahead and go to
Remington um you're going to need to be
in Remington for this money-making
method however so I mean realistically
you might as well just use someone
else's house because it's just as fast
but the reason you need to be in
Remington is because Phyllis or or V
vials I think this okay so vials I think
that's his name over here unnes things
for you so as you guys can see if I go
over here and use soft soft clay on him
I mean you can use anything but I'm
personally using soft clay people use
this a lot for dragon bones too you
exchange all for 110 GP and it gives you
full inventory of soft clay which is way
quicker than teleporting and Banking and
uh from there all you're going to want
to do is enter the
portal and go to a friend's house and
then whoever the host is all you need to
do is just stand out there and usually
there's someone telling who is the host
but if there isn't you can just ask
around um from there just walk over to
the election and and um this is where it
kind of becomes a thing of what you want
to do so there are different things that
you can do in this case um I think bones
to peaches and stuff like that you
actually do need to do like other side
stuff for but in this scenario basically
house teleports are the best one that I
can do so I didn't say this at the
beginning but you will need a baseline
magic level I I believe 40 magic is
pretty accessible to the average person
um some of the higher ones like maybe
Camelot I feel would be about the
highest you would get is only I mean
that's 45 but it's not too bad at all so
from here this is where there's some
variation depending on you know what
stuff's worth at the
time all right so from here I'm going to
go over to my sponsor GE tracker and if
you guys have the premium feature which
I do however it kind of shows you guys
what you can look for you can buy these
margins as well if you want but I'm just
using this as an example if you go down
to the moneymaking tab and then magic
tablets it'll show you what the best
profit is on each one that you can make
right now teleport to houses are 3 66 GP
profit off of each one um Enchanted
diamonds Enchanted sapphires are higher
however you barely sell on any hour so
that's why they're that high because you
know no one buys them um from there
teleport to houses are the best verac
teleports are about 120 GP less so at
the time of making this it's definitely
in your best interest to do te teleports
to houses however over time this may
change and if you don't want to go ahead
and use G tracker and you want to do
your own thing you can just buy and sell
it teleport in game minus the cost of
what it actually takes to make it and
then figure that out for yourself so
there'll be in the description down
below if you want to check that out they
have a ton of other merging tools but
let's get back over to the uh the old
school RuneScape so from there basically
all you're going to want to do is just
press make all on the house teleports
it's pretty self-explanatory and you
just sit here and Rack in Magic XP so
it's 30 XP per one and the inventory
takes about 70 seconds which isn't too
bad at all um basically the calculations
I came up with I'll go through here in a
second all right so in each inventory
you're going to go ahead and use 22
Earth runes right uh 22 law runes and 22
air runes so I'm going to go ahead and
put all of those in here along with 22
soft clay which means that each
inventory you're spending roughly 7.3k
to make in total what would be 22 house
teleports 22 house teleports in total
gets you about 15K so realistically
you're making you're practically
doubling your money after you add in the
cost that it's 110 GP to actually unnote
these so whatever money you come here
with you will be doubling um according
my calculations if you go ahead and make
about 7.5k off of each inventory you
should be making around something of 360
kgp per hour which is absolutely insane
I mean as far as low-level money-making
goes it's definitely worth your time um
especially if you're just wanting to
chill out watch some Netflix or do
whatever you want to do um it's
definitely the more way the more chill
way to go about training magic and uh
it's profitable so God I am all over the
place I hope this uh money-making guide
was helpful if this really isn't your
couple tea and you're more of a highle
money-making um or if you're more of a
high-leveled account looking for a
better money-making method that does
involve Mage because that's what kind of
was implied in the title in the in the
thumbnail and whatnot um go ahead and
check out a video of mine it was a
couple months ago it's called I have to
go look it up this is
embarrassing it's called AFK magic XP
and profit and I will leave that as a
link in description down below since I
can't put annotations and end screen
stuff in the same video so if you guys
want to check that out your higher level
uh account and think that you can do
that and with that you'll be getting
about 200k GP per hour which is
obviously a little less but you'll be
getting about 60k magic XP which is uh
insane and even if you're a lower level
and just want something to kind of like
strive for in game go ahead and check
that out that'll be in the description
down below but uh yeah if you guys
enjoyed the video make sure to leave a
like if you guys have anything you want
to tell me leave a comment especially if
you guys like some lower level money
making methods I know I've kind of
thrown those out the window and not
really gone with them but it's something
I'm looking to uh kind of revisit um as
well you can hit me up in game either PM
me sometimes at just at large exp exp
lamp join 07 helpers hit up the Twitter
in the description down below but
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace all right so I
didn't I didn't put this in the guide
but just remember to tip the person
whose house you're using whatever you
feel comfortable tipping because they
are providing a service for you so uh
yeah without any tips they wouldn't do
this so just remember that
[Music]
d